hey it's jenny and we're out here in
monroe county i've got my new friend
with me jackson jackson say hi yeah he's
already ready how hot do you think it is
today 93 degrees
he knew that right off top of his head
i'm going to go with about 5000 degrees
but
whatever and today we're laying poly
pipe in the field behind me
[Music]
okay what what does poly pipe do
um it helps water our fields helps water
here okay helps water your fields and
what field will we be watering um
don't know the exact name of it but
bean field a bean filled all right well
um do we actually need that today or is
that just to keep some no people back
because we'll be needing this try and
just check and just want to make sure
for my safety
um all right so before we lay i mean do
we need to get stretching do we need to
be limber for this what no you're just
gonna be walking to the other end of the
field
okay you're not gonna do it okay i'm
gonna get my toes
and i'm just gonna limber it this way
and this way you know feel free to join
in any time that you think
okay all right that's fine all right
what is this
um it's
um
a pivot from where the pipe comes out of
the ground okay so this is like our
water source yeah so the well over there
is sucking out of the ground and there's
a pipe that brings it up here and
okay and this is the poly yeah that
we're laying all right so what are we
going to do we're going to follow
this tractor cisco uh-huh and he's going
to be making a ditch underneath there
and it's going to stretch it out across
the field and then about
this row and that row will get water but
this row won't
okay
okay all right and what are we going to
do behind it um i got to put dirt on it
so it doesn't blow off all right well
why don't i follow you you can show me
how to do that and maybe i can give it a
go maybe yeah would you be cool with
that yeah all right cool
all right
so we're trying to water from this side
of the field because there's a hill
slanting that way and the water will
fall down there okay
but we're going to lay it across this
way for it to go that way
all right all right let's see this let's
take some dirt
all right so this takes a
this takes a lot of concentration
no that i mean
what did you say no
you're walking on a poly pipe
yeah but there's like
dirt everywhere
i mean i guess
i feel like this is
i'm just waiting to eat it you know
well if you eat it you'd probably have
stitches in your chin
okay that's good
chill chill
do you have you ever fallen doing this
yes okay that makes me feel better
[Music]
five steps
put a shovel of dirt on the pipe all
right let's do it you switch
like right here yeah
is that enough
probably just a shovel
you're making this look a lot
smoother
we sure did pick a hot day didn't we
yeah
it's good in hot day too
that's half of the work
[Music]
half the work
cool
cool cool all right i'm gonna grab some
of that water
[Music]
all right jackson
what we got here today it's a well
it pulls water out of the ground to
put it in our poly pipe so we can pop
them all right so what we just laid down
water is about to flow through it and
that's all coming from here yes so what
do we what do what what do you have to
do to make this
flow you just turn a lever
he turns it on
that's it you just turn it on you turn
it on water shows up all right and we're
about to go
pop
what do we call it a popper a popper is
what you have yes this is not a medieval
weapon this is an agriculture
icon i don't know
popper yeah all right so you're gonna
show me how we do the popper next yep
all right well let's go do it
[Applause]
no idea we got adult kid farmer john
over here
do you know that was gonna happen yes on
that weld down there that's what it's
called right yeah we laid the poly pipe
and that water is
pushing through here
okay
and then what we take that poker that
you had yeah we gotta find that thing
and we basically poke holes in here and
that's so the water
shoots down that way
anything else we need to know about this
like what what's happening down there
what's cisco doing down at the uh he's
holding water pressure down there so the
water can't go past him okay okay
anything else about this are there
certain hole are there certain size
holes yeah there's a bunch you can have
an inch half inch
all the variations and it depends on how
long your field is so
if you have like a really short and
skinny field you could do like an inch
hole
but if you had a long field like we have
here we're doing half inch today so when
we're done when you're done with this
poly pipe when you're done watering
filled what do you do with it oh we
recycle it you recycle it
make the world a better place
[Music]
figure words of
are better than me being over there
[Music]
good hard day's work jackson
yeah yeah but we're not nearly done wait
what why are we still not done
no i gotta rest a day to go
oh all right well
i think my job's here
it's done
thank you so much for helping me like
polly pot
it's been good
i'm gonna go uh
hit your ride somewhere over there
you